bonjour le mélomane un don qui est bien
content ce 21 juin et bonjour claude
césaire bonjour je martinique 1ère merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation que le
teaser vous êtes pianiste donc
professeur de musique musicien et
professeur de musique vous êtes
responsable pédagogique un concernant
donc la musique et la danse à la coup
semblait matinik la coup semblait matnik
donc qui est une école de musique située
à h el cheikh ne paie qu'à exactement
c'est ça un établissement polyvalent un
espace polyvalent d'expression
culturelle et artistique et donc on vous
inviter en ce 21 juin une c'est une date
un jour que vous devez apprécier tout
particulièrement vous qui avez baigné
dedans tout petit puisqu'il faut le
rappeler également vous êtes le fils
donc des manuel césaire plus connu sous
le surnom de mano césaire musiciens très
célèbre en martinique et qui a notamment
fait partie du groupe malavoi alors 21
juin c'est la fête
oui c'est la fête et surtout savez il ya
un jeu de fête de la musique est faite
f ayité et voilà de faire faire de la
musique exactement voilà alors je
regarde je vais
partager avec vous souvenir parce que je
me rappelle les premières éditions à
paris et tout j'étais encore étudiant et
d'eau et quand se joue est arrivé et
puis à huit heures du matin on descend
je descends de mon immeuble
dans mon appartement et puis et puis en
fin de compte une autre ambiance tant
dans les huiles dans les rues et tous on
n'entend pas des claques sont uniquement
des voitures mais enfin quand on entend
de la musique et ça m'avait frappé parce
que j'étais page avait pas encore eu
vent les formations il dit mais qu'est
ce qui se passe à paris et tout mais
enfin quand je découvre que en fin de
compte que la france avait a été le
premier pays à nationaliser en fin de
compte cet événement c'est un événement
qui a été créée par le musicien tout
amérique et dans les années soixante dix
mais effectivement à la france est le
premier soyez et joel coen pour en vivre
en france
mais là dans les années soixante seize
qui voulaient célébrer la musique
le solstice d'été dans l'hémisphère nord
donc le 21 juin
voilà tout à fait mais la france est
elle sera le premier pays à nationaliser
enfin quand cet événement est
aujourd'hui il semblerait qu'il ya plus
de 100 pays dans le monde qui en fait
qu'on qui ont suivi c'est quelque chose
a répondu nous sommes en fin de compte à
à une attente
voilà alors rapidement c'est pourquoi je
dis ça parce que pour moi ce que j'ai
retenu de ce moment c'était c'était une
sorte de libération musicale une
explosion musicale surtout pour ce qui
est qu'ils n'ont pas la possibilité de
s'exprimer sur des scènes et je moi mais
j'ai gardé ça en mémoire je me rappelle
il y avait un monsieur qui avait
descendu sa batterie sur l'autre 3 et
tous et puis la joue de la batterie
pendant toute la journée
moi ça va moi ça m'avait frappé parce
que ça nous connaissons les restrictions
à paris un proulx pouvoir et tout
s'était c'était c'était le seul jour
dans l'année où quelque peu les gens
s'exprimer oui claude césaire parce que
initialement c'est vrai que c'est une
incitation aux musiciens amateurs
par opposition aux musiciens
professionnels oublient tous les aaa se
produire voilà dans le cadre d'une
grande manifestation populaire mais qui
permettent effectivement à tous les
musiciens de s'exprimer de se faire
connaître
ainsi voilà ce qui joue au piano qui
joue de la guitare de temps en temps
chez eux
voilà
leur salon voilà voilà l'amateur pense
que nous avons eu des musées amateurs
qui se produisent sur les scènes
oui bien sûr zapato le mais surtout aux
amateurs qui n'ont pas la possibilité de
d'accéder à une scène où un lieu de
spectacle et ou alors est-ce que cet
esprit initial perdure encore après
plusieurs années puisque la première
fête de la musique c'était en 1992 voilà
c'est ça tout à fait alors c'est clair
que de toutes les manières vu
l'envergure je crois qu'en bien sûr le
monde du showbiz s'est emparé le plus de
l'événement mais tout bon voilà est bon
et c'est vrai qu'on a vu on a dû
s'organiser ce jour là de grandes
manifestations
généralement occupées par des
professionnels voilà pas bon alors c'est
s est s était prévisible que ces
événements soient aussi récupéré par les
leon à dire par le par le milieu et tout
ça bon maintenant l'important c'est que
c'est qu'il faut pas voilà ce que dans
l'avalanche facile d équilibre voilà
c'est surtout sa voix lors c'est surtout
ça a un bon ça fait longtemps je suis
pas retourné à paris sait pas comment ça
se passe mais moi j'avais retenu cette
spontanéité collectif et tous qui était
qui et aimait vraiment qui était
merveilleuse et les gens dans la rue et
tout ça je sais pas si ça se passe comme
ça mais ça serait dommage que
effectivement à paris mais ici mais ici
alors que j'en passe car martinique
les choses sont on nous vivons les
choses différemment parce que je pense
que la musique est omniprésente
artistique toute l'année et tout je peux
comprendre que parisiens soient frustrés
de ne pas pouvoir s'exprimer parce qu'il
est dans son appartement il est allé à
des voisins ou à gauche à droite et tout
ça mais en martinique je crois que la
musique est quelque chose de death cris
dans la culture dans la dans le
quotidien des martiniquais alors fait
contre la musique pour moi en fait je
sais pas si comment les martiniquais
perçoivent cet événement est ce qu'ils
la perçoivent comme quelque chose
d'exceptionnel dans la nuit par les
pressions parce que nous allons entrer
dans une période à où il y aura des
festivités commencent à la nouvelle
orléans navale
non nous sommes sommes un peuple de
de musique un de fait nous faisons la
fête souvent dans l'année donc c'est une
date de plus l'utilisation parmi
d'autres voila voila j'ai l'impression
que c'est la perception que moi je
pensais mais je pense que ça ne va pas
forcément marqué les esprits comme dans
d'autres pays
alors justement cette date de la fête de
la musique c'est l'occasion également
avec vous claude césaire de parler
justement des plus jeunes comment les
initiés donc à la musique et puis aussi
comment transmettre notre patrimoine
musical alors vous êtes bien placé pour
en parler parce que vous même vous avez
publié il n'ya pas longtemps je crois
qu'il ya à peine deux ans une méthode
pour jouer pour interpréter la musique
traditionnelle martiniquaise au piano
voilà c'est ça alors une méthode de
piano en fin de compte qui qui propose
enfin quand une initiation musique
traditionnelle dès les premières années
voilà ce ouvrage en fin de compte qui
n'existaient pas parce que généralement
le piano ne connaissons les origines du
piano et là on va dévoiler les premiers
pas de deux ans on va dire de quelqu'un
qui veut enfin compte initiaux à
l'instrument généralement avec avait
approuvé on va dire des généralement des
documents des méthodes plutôt classique
voilà alors je mettais toujours
questionné sur le fait que parce que
j'ai eu une formation classique que
quand on m'apprenait un jouet des
petites pièces de bach ou d'imposants
qu'en fin de compte que souvent ces
pièces appelait menuet sarabande bourré
et après que les études je m'étais rendu
compte que tous ces nombres en fait
compte était tout simplement dhainaut de
danses populaires et traditionnelles
c'est à dire qu'en fin de compte ces
grands compositeurs écrivait aussi en
s'inspirant des musiques traditionnelles
de l'un de leur région de leur pays
voilà l'idée me dis mais pourquoi en
martinique
ne pourrait-on pas levée ne pourrait-on
pas le faire et vous l'avez fait des
voix oui mais voilà c'est ça je veux un
plus et là la chose me dit bon est ce
que est ce que c'est ni ap à quelques
pas un décalage entre
une danse européenne du xviie siècle et
la réalité culturelle de la martinique
voila voila c'était ça mais bon après il
m'a fallu c'était pas si simple parce
que nous avons quand on écrit de la
musique surtout la musique
traditionnelle et où il ya quand même il
ya quand même des paramètres qu'il faut
tenir compte nous avons une conception
du rythme qui est pas la même que la
musique européenne
il fallait quelque part que je je je
fasse des recherches pour voir comment
quelque part traduire ça transpire ça
pour des butins voilà alors justement
vous parlez de débutants on a
l'impression que chez nous vous le vous
le disiez bon c'est vrai la musique et
est là partout dans l'air beaucoup
d'appelés peu d'élus finalement au final
au bout du compte c'est vrai que ce cas
une déperdition
au fil des années vous voyez ce que je
veux dire voilà alors surtout surtout
ceux qui voudraient devenir musicien
professionnel c'est pas évident en
particulier chez nous et souvent il faut
partir à un moment oui alors sportif
lent et un sur le terrain bon jeu je
n'irai pas trop d'un enfin je n'ai pas
la même
la même analyse nous avons au niveau de
la jeunesse nous avons encore un gros
potentiel nous avons reçu sans contact
avec des enfants permanent puisque vous
êtes enseignant comme ça et tout ça même
ou si j'étais à bien des écoles dans des
collèges et tous nous avons encore un
gros potentiel et non simplement c'est
que c'est l'environnement des enfants
qui qui n'est pas le même voilà c'est à
dire quoi par exemple puis son
environnement moins favorable ki moon
sur cet aspect c'est surtout par exemple
pour la transmission des musiques
traditionnelles la biguine mazurka
pratiquement c'est pas quelque
chose qui qui fait partie qui s'inscrit
dans leur environnement proche
voilà alors y apprend donc au travail
d'éducation à faire et au niveau des
écoles pour aussi si on veut que ces
musiques en fin de compte ce sera soit
pérenne et et se transmettent
merci claude césaire donc responsable
pédagogique à l'école là coup semblait
matheny khl cher musicien professeur de
musique au hip hop en quelques mots et
quelques nouveaux conclure la coup
semblait enfin quand présente ses élèves
au village de mu de la musicale de la
ville de schoelcher cet après midi entre
17h et 18h donc ce soit ce soir voilà eh
bien le rendez vous est donné merci
bonne journée bonne fête de la musique a
à toutes et à tous merci